okay well then we're gonna start off
today by first closing off this is a
question you looked at on last time
right was that Tuesday Tuesday afternoon
okay this is all our questions youth I'm
some of you had trouble looking at and
then we'll have a look at a couple more
different kinds of cases still under the
heading of rational corner okay so we've
led so far I'm just looking at this and
trying to rephrase it right we get ahead
toward integration but just so I don't
have to write integral of DX integral DX
many many times before I actually get to
the integration I'm just gonna leave it
like that okay now can someone tell me
why is it that our normal strategy for
dividing this up into partial fractions
why is it that our normal strategy fails
why is it that unnormal strategy fails
now just before I show you why it fails
that weddings important how do you get
that I don't know when I was going
through your 11 classic example you in
three unit right what kinds of things do
you learn understanding of tree you
learn how to solve equations then you
learn or Tillery angle then you learn
general solution then you let in T
method and a lot of them they really
overlap don't they and I remember I
distinctly remember thinking myself why
are we learning so many ways of doing
the same thing like is it just because
they want to make life hard
the answer is no it's because those
strategies they sometimes fail so you
use different alternatives right and
this is exactly what's happening here
okay
what's this denominator it's X minus 2
times X minus 2 so if you were to break
it up into one fraction over here for
one factor and another one over here you
would end up with this right those are
the two factors right but because the
double factor it doesn't like why not
what's the problem keeping in mind that
um a and B they just
good morning the reason it breaks down
is or maybe I should say the reason why
partial fractions usually works is when
you put these two together right you
have to get a common denominator you end
back where you started right but you
don't need to do anything like that when
you put these on a comment it'll move
because they already have a common
denominator X minus 2 this one's linear
but it's not quadratic you're so you're
stuck ok so the question is how can we
do something still with this to form
partial fractions okay what must one of
these denominators be in order to end up
with an X minus 2 or squared right any
answer is one of them has to be an X
minus 2 or squared okay now some of you
may not have written it like this you
still would have gotten this same
expression at the end but this is the
way that I'm going to advise that you
actually follow through because it means
you start off in much the same way and
basically you can proceed as usual so
watch okay on the right hand side I'm
gonna put everything together
okay now that to do that I need the
common denominator over here so I might
do this in another color so you can see
what's going on if I want this is a
common denominator right I'll have to
multiply by X minus 2 over here so I do
to the top as well now you can see my
numerators I can compare right so I've
got this okay now at this point we're in
a good position right because there's a
trick we can take advantage of that will
even though we've got so many unknowns
we can work out what some of them are
right what might you suggest think about
the way you normally do partial
fractions yeah let's let's try out when
x equals 2 right because that's going to
eliminate this part over here right so
by now you've done this a few times
you're gonna see what's going to happen
you probably don't need to put in every
line of working over here what are you
gonna get 8 minus 7 1 over here this X
minus 2 will vanish so you just get a
right cool good I've got one day
from here there are two ways to get the
other values okay
any suggestions okay so the first way I
could do it let's go over here is I
could equate coefficients I just have to
take this value right stick it in here
but I need to of expand everything out
okay so let's do that
I'll get 4x minus 7 equals 1 plus BX
minus B okay so you look we have two
coefficients here right I don't really
need to worry about these guys because
they're the constants right what I'm
really interested in is these that makes
the easiest comparison of a
straightforward one there are a 4x over
here and B over here they have to be the
same there's nowhere else for the XS to
come from right so just like an auxilary
angle you can say well B what's equal 4
by comparison of okay now by the way I
said that's not the only way to do it is
there what could you suggest okay I can
actually put a value in right which by
the way is sort of like if you had if
you did have a factor here which we
usually do right that's getting rid of
that that value over there right so I
would say instead of when x equals to 0
is just the easiest number I can put in
right so when x equals 0 what am I
getting the left hand side just negative
7 I already know what a is and then I've
got negative 2 lots of big right so just
tighten that up they do to be negative 8
no surprises
okay so now you can rewrite your
original rational polynomial and turn
your partial fractions
do you need me integrate or do you think
you can handle it from there Ricky I
think you could do it just watching out
for this Tokyo right because you're used
to things like this turning into logs
right but this does not turn into a log
because it's squared right if you have
trouble with working out what that is
just let me know I'll show you ok